so the darkness is is pre-biblical you
know it predates God and heaven and hell
and Crowley and Castiel
and so Sam being the diligent researcher
is just trying to think of I think his
brain is swimming thinking of like what
can we do how can we what is this thing
how can we get to the bottom of how to
fix it how can I save myself and my
brother and the world and so he starts
to have visions or dreams of a higher
power you know and maybe his brain he's
also having memories that maybe weren't
memories might be his beep Sam believes
there was a higher power trying to
contact him to tell him how to solve
this problem you know so it's gonna be
really cool cuz we're gonna see a few
characters via visions that we haven't
seen in super in a long time
one may or may not be related to the
character I'm excited for y'all heard
the tease about em so for all takes
place in the car it's called baby and so
it's like yeah and well it's gonna be a
really cool it's one of the things like
supernatural is the only show on
television that took it away with it
because you all forgive us and embrace
it and it's different you know I mean I
played Jared Padalecki on Supernatural
before literally so let's get that's
true that's right so we're gonna see
kind of like an episode of Supernatural
from the point if not the point of view
because we will see the car as well
it'll be cool things where it's the
cameras inside the car and one of the
brothers runs in to grab something and
it's off-camera you hear some stuff it
runs back and he's bloody and it's gonna
be a cool like we get to see we forget
sometimes that the impalas been all the
places with us so I kinda see how baby
views an episode of Supernatural let's
go be super cool
yeah that's for me that's super exciting
because we've had too many years of like
they've been great years and great
stories but there's been binney's and
rubies and solace and campbell's and
Lucifer and Mark of Cain so we've got
all these reasons for the brothers to
kind of be a part and now because the
darkness is so vast and seemingly
insurmountable the brothers are side by
side teamed up again which for me is is
badass I love I love that part of
supernatural and the brothers kind of
team up and they're loyal and they
sacrifice and they're together now
I hope she's a big problem cuz I love
her and she's awesome and I love seeing
this evening she and Mark Sheppard so I
think she she's certainly a foil of
sorts and she will be around hopefully
for a long long time but I love the
dynamic I love seeing not just because
it means I have the day off but I love
seeing part supernatural that I'm not an
you know like seeing their problems in
heaven or seeing the plums in hell and
seeing problems it's cuz it flushes out
the world you know it's not just like
hairs what the boys did it flushes out
the world of supernatural you know and
so I hope she's around for a while I
hope she gives more trouble to probably
than to the boys though Oh any teammate
I would like I would love to see Rob
Benedict come back I would love to see
much Pileggi came back as I love match
I think it'll be fun to employ some
angels because this the darkness
predates angels it'd be fun to see if
Gabriel is out and about somewhere
they'd be fun to get back in action I
had so much fun in seasons four and five
with the whole demon blood and the angel
characters and Lucifer room it'd be fun
to have any of those guys back to try
and maybe unite against a common massive
enemy well like we were sitting in the
makeup trailer and someone was like whoa
what are the boys gonna do and I was
like you ain't to lose jesters and we
were like wait a second has we ever even
said that an episode or anything I was
like no I just coined it I gotta like a
partner or something before I hope so
it'd be a funny there be something like
that that goes through the ghostfacers
what's call
the lose Chester's or something like
that so maybe with the ghostfacers back
then we'll work it into an episode
otherwise I'll just keep saying I like a
broken record I'm hoping for like
sympathy laughs you know somebody please
please leave please
you